[müzik]
Evet, ABS'nin gülü. Şimdi geldim neye?
En sevdiğim yere. Tarih öncesi
devirlere. Yani kısaca töt dediğimiz
yere geldik. Nereye gelmişiz? Töt
dediğimiz yere gelmişiz. Tarih öncesi
devirler. Tamam. Benim en sevdiğim yer
burası. Niye biliyor musun abim? Lan bir
tane bilgi yok. Tamamen atmasyon,
sallamasyon, üfürmasyon, ne bilen
nelasyon öyle bir yer. Tamam. Benim en
sevdiğim yer burası. Şimdi arkana yaslan
lisentum çok veri kerfele. Hadi
bismillahirrahmanirrahim. Gel bakalım bu
kameraya. Gel bakalım şimdi. Abis dur
vazgeçtim. Orta kameraya gel. Vazgeçtim
şimdi. Aa burada vazgeçtim kandırdım.
Dur fake [kahkaha] attım
gözüm üstünde bak. Bekle. Tamam. Şimdi
tarih öncesi devrler abiciğim ikiye
ayrılı olur. Tamam mı? Taş devri, maden
devri diye. Herifler taşı kullanmış, taş
devri, madeni kullanmışlar. Maden devri
diye. Biz önce nereyi halledeceğiz? Önce
burayı halledeceğiz. Hadi o tarafa
geçiyoruz. Geldim bu kameraya. Tamam. A
taş devrini kendi içinde üçe ayırmışız.
Ne demişiz? Eski taş paraleolitik,
önceki adıyla karanlık. Tamam. Orta taş
mezolitik, önceki adıyla yontma taş.
Sonra yeni taş neolitik yani cilalı taş
dediğiniz yerle. Buranın isimleri falan
komple sürekli değişiyordu. İşte
anlatıyorduk yontma taş, lalı taş diye.
Şimdi ne diye geçiyor? Orta taş, yeni
taş, bilmem ne diye geliyor. Tamam. Ya
eski soruları çözerken görürsünüz
onları. Ama burası şu an tamamen
değişmiş vaziyette. Neden? Çünkü Urfa
Göbeklitepe'deki o bulunan o mabet
burayı komple allak bullak etti
abiciğim. Tamam. Hah. Şimdi arkana
yazsana. Ama genel yapısıyla biz
bilelim. Niye biliyor musun? Çünkü
burayla alakalı kesin net bilgiler yok.
Çünkü bir şey yok. Ne yok? Yazı yok la.
Yazı yok. Tamam. Adam kazıyor bir tane
ıbrık buluyor, çanak buluyor, çömlek
buluyor, bir şey buluyor. Ona göre
yorumluyoruz. Bak 600.000 yıllık dönemi
neyle yorumlayacağım şimdi? Biraz sonra
göreceksin. Tamam. Arkana yasan. Aha taş
devri. İnsanlık ilk önce neyle
uğraşıyor? Taşla. Sonra toprakla sonra
madene geçeceğiz. Tamam. Taş devri. Eski
taş paleolitik dönem dediğimiz yer. Yani
milattan önce 600.000lere kadar gidiyor.
Daha öncesi var mı? Var. Fakat biz
bilmiyoruz. İşte dünyanın ortaya
çıkışıyla alakalı işte var ya o Big Bang
teorisi kabul görüyor. İşte dünya
güneşten kopmuş gelmiş dört ded je işte
jeolojik zaman geçirmiş soğumuş falan
falan falan falan değil mi ama burası
dinler tarihle Kur'an'la İncille
Tevrat'la oralarla tutmuyor. Mesela
Enbiya 30'da değil mi? Hemen bir
bakıverin bakalım. Önce sular sonra
karılar yaratıldı diye anlatılıyor. E
ama şimdi modern bilim bunu ispat
edemediği için şimdi biliyoruz dinler
tarihinde Hazreti Adem diye bir
peygamber var. Ee e şimdi öncesi sonrası
işte bazı şeyler bilim ispatlayamayınca
tamam mı orada boşluklar oluşuyor. O
yüzden burada bilinmezlik var. Dinler
tarihiyle dinlerle tamam mı? Din
ilahiyat işte işleriyle tarih modern
bilim biraz burada çelişiyor. Tamam.
Şimdi bakıyorsun Hazreti Adem diye
anlatılıyor. Öbür tarafta neondartel,
Homo sapiens bilmem neler falan falanlar
diye anlatılıyor. Çok aynısına
girmeyeceğim ben. Tamam. Bunun daha
öncesi alakalı insanlığın elinde net
bilgi yok. Tamam. İşte ilk insanın
ortaya çıktığından bahsediliyor. Tamam.
Arkasından mağara ağaç kovuklarında bir
yaşam var. E nerede yaşacak acaba? Şey
mi var? Apart mı var? Aynı günümüzde
nasıl apart bulamıyorsan, kiralık daire
bulamıyorsan o dönemde yokmuş. Ne yapsın
adamlar? Gariplerin nerede yaşıyor?
Mağarada, ağaç kovuklarında yaşıyor. Ve
neyle uğraşıyor? Avcılık, toplayıcılıkla
uğraşıyor. Ha şimdi kısmi iş bölümü de
vardır diyebilirsiniz. İşte erkekler
avlıyor, kızlar topluyor gibi bir şey
diyebilirsiniz ama cinsiyet ayrımı var
mı yok mu? sosyal onu hala tartışır.
Tamam. Ama insanoğlu burada bileceğiniz
olay şu. İnsanoğlu bu dönem doğada
üretici değil. Doğada tüketici. Tamam.
Bir şey üretmiyoruz ki. Var olanı
tüketiyoruz. Ama şimdi avla topla, avla
topla, avla topla. Şu bölgede
yaşıyorduk. E başka bölgeler var mı
bilmiyoruz. Gidebilecek cesaret var mı?
O da yok. Niye? Her an bir sivri dişli
kaplan gelebilir. Her an bir dinozor
çıkabilir. Her an bir uçan bir kuş seni
alıp götürüp yiyebilir. Değil mi?
Etkileşim az bu dönem. İnsanoğlu artık
dağılmış dünyanın neresine nasıl
dağıldıysa. O da kocaman bir soru
işareti. Tamam. İnsanoğlu bu dönem
tüketici. E avladım, topladım, avladım,
topladım. Bir zaman sonra bitti. Bu
bölgede şuduk tükettik kaynakları. Hoppa
neyiz bu dönem? Göçebeyiz. Tamam. Bu
dönem göçebeyiz. Bitti bak. Ezberleme.
Tamam. Mantık anla. Peki bu dönem insan
mı doğaya hükmediyor yoksa doğa mı
insana hükmediyor? Bu dönem doğa insana
hükmediyor. Onun şartlarına göre
yaşıyoruz. Ve dönemin karakteristik
özelliklerinden birisi taş balta. Buraya
da alabilirsiniz taş baltayı. Tamam.
Hah. Ama taş balta şimdi abi sabahtan
akşama bak o dönem şartlarında var ya
bak yakışıklı, karizma, güzel falan
bunlar 10 para etmiyor. Niye? Ulan
karnın aç. Karnın tamam mı? Bir şey
yakalayıp bir şey y bir şey yemen lazım
ki karnın doysun değil mi? E sabahtan
akşama kadar neyin peşinde
koşturuyorsun? Bip bip. Rotruner denilen
bir tane ceylan var. Tamam mı? Onun
peşinde koşturuyorsun. Bak bir tane o
dönem ortalama bir insan işte 4550 km
hızla koşar. En hızlıımız Hüseyin Bod 60
küsür kilometreyle koşuyor galiba. Tamam
ama Ceylan 0'dan 100'e 2,5 saniyede
çıkıyor. Senin onu yakalaman mümkün
değil. Sabahtan akşama kadar onun
peşinde koşturuyoruz. Koş koş koş koş
koş koş koş koş koş koş koş koş koş koş
koş. Eee geldik. Karnın kurul kurul
gurul. Tamam. Bir gün eline bizim eleman
taş almış. Bir tane de sopa almış.
Taştan sopayla bunu koşturuyor,
kovalıyor. Derken ayağa takılmış. Allah
demiş. Böyle sopayı koyduğuyla üstüne
taşı geçirmiş. Al sana taş balta.
Benim teorim bu. Bence mantıklı. Anladın
mı? Yani hani bilmiyoruz ki lan işte.
Atıyoruz işte burayı. Tamam. A
karakteristik özellik. Taş balta ve bu
dönemin en önemli özelliklerinden
birisi. Ateş denetim altına alındı. Ama
burayla alakalı akademik çalışmalarda
sıkıntılar var. akademik bilgilerle
bazen çelişiyor. Orta taşta mı, yontma
taşta mı, burada mı, orada mı falan bu
soruldu daha öncesinde eee öğretmenlik
sınavlarının birisinde soruldu. İptal
ettilerdi soruyu. Haberiniz olsun. Ateş
denetim altına almış. Bak ateş bulundu
demiyorum. Ateş zaten vardı. Tamam. Biz
ne olduğunu bilmiyorduk. Nasıl
kullanacağımızı bilmiyorduk. Nasıl
kontrol edeceğimizi bilmiyorduk. Ve ateş
denetimi altına alındı. Nasıl? Bunda buz
devrinde sit.
Dahil miyim neyim ben? Mağara zoruna
resim çizerken öyle olsun senin gizi
kabalık. Hanım hanım bunlar benim
yavrularım derken mağaraya silerken
oradan çakmakta silah neyi buldu? Herf
ateşi buldu. Peki ateşi bulduk biz.
Ateşi nerede kullandık? Önce pişirme. Oh
artık çiğ yemekten kurtuldum. Cızbız
köfte bu dönem başladı. İlk mangal ne
zaman yakılmış? Palit dönemde yakılmış.
Tamam. Arkasından pişirmede kullandık.
Savunmada kullandık. O sişli kaplan
artık böyle ateşi şey yapıyorsun,
sallıyorsun. Beraberinde savunmada
kullandığımız gibi ısınmada kullandık.
Artık üşümeye son kombileri kapattık.
Ateşimizi yaktık değil mi? Aydınlanma da
kullandık. E akşama kadar zört zört
gezdin, çıktın geldin üç katlı tripleks
mağaraya. Nasıl aydınlatacaksın? Al.
Aydınlanma, savunma, ısınma, pişirme.
Ateşi çok yerde kullandık mı? Kullandık.
Ve ateş bu dönem önemli bir şey. Eğer
ateş olmayaydı, tamam. Eğer ateş
olmayaydı şu seramik sanatı olmazdı.
Hemen yanına çarpıyı koyayım. Geniş
açıya geç. Tamam. Seramik sanatı
olmazdı. Toprağı pişiremezdik. Eğer ateş
olmayaydı maden devri de olmazdı.
Bakıra, tunça, demire nasıl şekil
vereceksin? O yüzden ateş önemli. Bak
bağlantılı. Gel şimdi ilk kameraya gel.
Ve bu dönem karakteristik
özelliklerinden birisi taş balta ateştim
altına al dedik ki ya bir de
karakteristik özellik var. Mağara
duvarlarına resimler yapıyoruz. Bak
dervişin zikri neyse fikri de odur
hesabı. Sabahtan akşama kadar neyin
peşinde koşturuyorsun?
O Ceylan'ın peşinde koşturuyorsun.
Mağaraya geldin. Karnın kurul kurul
ediyor mu? Ediyor değil mi? Adam eline
aldı taşı. Kalem de yok o dönem. Taşı
aldı. Mağara duvarına resimleri çizdi.
Hı hı.
Bu ne? Şu da kuyruğu. Bu ne? Ceylan. L.
Ceylan, Ceylan, Ceylan. He, beğenmiyor
musun? Ama bunu var ya ilkel sanatsal
etkinlikler diye yorumluyor ÖSYM ve şu
beğenmediğin Ceylan'dan. Tamam mı? Ben
şimdi sana bak neler çıkarıyorum. Hım.
Demek ki bu insanoğlu av figürü
çizdiğine göre neyle uğraşıyor? Avcılık
ve toplayıcılıkla uğraşıyor. Demek ki bu
adam tüketici. Demek ki bu adam göçebe.
Yanında bir tane taş palta resmi var.
Değil mi? Mağaraya yapmış değil mi? Al
beğenmediğin 600.000 yıllık şeyi bir
tane resimle hallediyoruz. Bak Buz Devri
1 diye bir film var. Benim en sevdiğim
filmlerden biridir o. Tamam. Vallaha bir
izle. Yeminle bak daha o daha ayrıntılı
daha akademik bilgiyle. Anladın mı yani?
A bu yok abim bilgi yok. Yeni bir kaz
bulunur, bir şey bulunur. Burası komple
değişir yani. İşte al beğenmediğin bir
resimden neler çıkıyor? Al sana ilkel
sansal etkinlikler çıktı mı? Çıktı.
beraberinde bu dönem artık insanlar
yaşıyor ama bu dönemin sonuna doğru
havalar soğumaya başlamış. Artık bu
dönem mi sonudu bu dönem mi soğudu o da
bilinmez. Havaların soğumasıyla
başlamasıyla beraber insanoğlu nerelere
doluştu? İnsanoğlu mağaralara doluşmaya
başladı. Ama şimdi burada bireysellik
vardı. Tamam mı? Gemisini kurtaran
kaptanıdı. Ama şimdi soğuk. Tamam.
Millet mağaralara geldi. Artık böyle
şeye değil. Tamam. Nerede çokluk orada.
Bereket hesabı. Geldik mağaraya.
unga bunga baktım kalabalık var bir
yerde böyle girdim içeride ateş yanıyor.
Tamam eline almış eleman gitarı. My lady
darban tın tın tının tının vay duyuluk
sobın tın tın tın tın. Mağarada ateş
yanıyor. Otantik bir ortam. Gitar
çalıyor değil mi? Ondan sonrasında
mağara içinde şöyle bir bakmaya
başladım. Orada birisi var. Hah. H.
Allah. Allah.
Ama orada böyle baktım saçı uzun, gözü
renkli. Öyle. O da boncuk boncuk. Bana
bakıyor. Böyle ona baktım.
He lan.
He
ne güzel gözlerin varmış. Öyle olsun.
Sen gidi kabarık işte kuzu kuzu geldim
derken mağaralarda ne başladı? Aşk
başladı. Aşk. Aşk. Al. Adam ne? Gülme g
oradan duyuyorum bak mağaralarda aşk
başladı kurban olduğum işte mağaraya
girdik 50 kişi mağaradan çıktık 550 kişi
sosyolojideki klan aile kavramı ortaya
çıkmaya başladı mı ilkel aile kavramı
ortaya çıktı peki soru karı derz herif
der cız derdi. İlk nerede başlamış? Eski
taş partük'te başlamış. Peki ilk gelin
gaynana görün gelin işte elti eltilerin
savaşı görümcelerin birbirinin ümü
sıkması ne zaman başlamış? Burada
başlamış. Anladın? İlkel aile klan
kavramları yavaş yavaş ortaya çıkmaya
başlıyor. Hah beraberinde işte
Yarımburgaz, Karin buralara örnek
yerlerimizdir de Anadolu'daki yerlerdir.
Tamam. Sonra bir ne var? Orta taş
mezorotik denilen bir dönem var. Tamam.
Geçiş evresi. İşte mikrolitler,
obsidyenler, işte çakmak taşları, taş
aletler kullanılmaya başlamış. birazcık
daha çeşitlenmeye başlamış. Mesela köpek
evcilleştiriliyor. Abo köpek ha bu da
var ya bak bu da şeydi tartışmalıydı.
İlk evcilleştirilen hayvan nedir? Köpek
mi, inek mi, at mı, koyun mu, kuz mu?
Hangisi? Öncelerden inek diyorlardı. Bir
ara atıdı. Şimdi map kitabında ne
yazıyor? Köpek evcilleştirildi diyor.
Bilinmiyor ki abim. Yok hani bilgi yok,
belge yok, bir şey yok yani. Adam da şey
yapmamış. Ne bileceğiz? Köpek
evcilleştirilmiş. Hah. Burayı şöyle
yorumlayabilirsin. İnsanoğlu doğaya
hükmetmeye başlıyor mu yavaş yavaş? Bak
ipleri bize doğru geçiriyoruz. İşte
Antalya Öküzeni, Beldibi, Burdur, Barad
bizim olduğumuz yerler, oralar bu
dönemin şeyleridir. Burası geçiş dönemi.
Bak 600.000 yıl çok uzun bir süre değil
mi? Sonra 12.000 yıl. Sonra insanoğlu
yavaş yavaş böyle göl kenarlarında
yerleşim muhabbet. Yavaş yavaş göl
kenarına yerleşmeye başladık. Tamam.
Yerleşik yaşam başladı. beraberinde
tarım başladı. Ama hangisi önce bununla
alakalı hala tartışmalar sürüyor? Yani
insanoğlu önce yerleşik yaşama geçti,
sonra tarım mı yaptı yoksa önce tarım
yapıp sonra yerleşik yaşama mı geçti?
Burası belli değil. Akademisyenler hala
tartışıyor. Yani tavuk mu yumurtadan,
yumurta mı tavuktana geliyor mesele?
Gerçi onu da geçenlerde bir şey
bulduları cevap budur falan diye de sen
şunu bil. Ezberleme. Profesörün
vermediği cevabı sen peşinde koşturma.
Sen şunu bil. Yerleşik yaşam varsa tarım
vardır. Tarım varsa mutlaka ne vardır?
Yerleşik yaşam vardır. Şimdi insanlar
çıktılar mağaralardan kenarında göl
kenarında yerleşmeye başladı. Niye? Su
var. Su. Yaşaman için ne lazım? Su
lazım. Bak güneş olmadan yaşarsın. Yemek
olmadan yaşarsın. Tamam mı? Ama
Instagram olmadan da yaşarsın. TikTok
olmadan da yaşarsın. Ama su olmadan
yaşayamazsın. En önemli vücudun 1te '
zaten ne? Su. Dünyanın 1te ' zaten ne?
sudan oluşuyor. İlla ne lazım bize? Su
lazım. Bir de o su kenarlarında oralarda
balıklar var. Değil mi? Bir doğal daha
kolay yakalaması ve sabahtan akşama
kadar peşinden koşturduğum ceylan dönüp
dönüş nereye geliyor? O da göl kenarına
geliyor. Niye? Su lazım çünkü. Tamam. Ve
en son yerleşik yaşam işte köyler böyle
şeyler oluşmaya başladı yavaş yavaş. Ve
tarım üretimi. İnsanoğlu taşı bıraktı
toprağı incelemeye başladı. Baktı ki o
toprakta ot çıkıyor, iniyor, kuruyor,
soluyor, etiyor, bilmem ne. bir sürü
falan derken abi bunlar binlerce yıl
sürdü bak 10.000 yıl sürmüş. Anladın
yani şimdi bunu bunun sonunda bir şeye
de bağlayacağım. Soru tipine de
bağlayacağım. Tamam. Tarım ortaya çıktı.
Hah. Hayırlı uğurlu olsun. Artık
insanoğlu üretici konuma geçti mi? Evet.
Artık insanoğlu üretici. Bak dönemleri
karşılaştırarak sorarlar. Tamam. Burada
burada tüketiciydin artık nesin? Artık
üreticisin burada göçebeydin. Artık
burada nesin? Artık burada yerleşiksin.
Ama iki taraf içinde hala taş aletler
kullanılıyor diyebilir miyim? Bunu da
sordu. ÖSYM böyle sorularla geliyor.
Kaldırıp kabalı karpuz ezberleme.
Şişersin. Tamam. Beraberinde tarımla
beraber ne de ortaya çıktı? Kölecilik
muhabbeti de ortaya çıktı. Nasıl çıktı o
kölecilik? Bak şimdi. Tamam. Gel şu
kameraya gel. Köşedeki kameraya gel.
Gel. Tamam. Benim şimdi ekip
biçebileceğim topraklar bu kadar olsun.
Tamam mı? O dönemin şartlarında tarım
yapabileceğim ama işte atıyorum bir
dönüm olsun. Tek başıma işte yapacağım
ya bu kadar olsun. Kimim ben bu dönem
yaşadığıma göre? Ben şu adam olayım.
Bakalım benzedebilecekiz mi? Genelde
benzediyorum ama bunu da tren
yolculuğunda üniversite öğrencisiyken
Kore gazisi bir amcadan öğrendiydim.
Kime benzedi? Fred'e benzedi mi Fred?
Fred iri. Fred kalafatlı. Fred böyle
güçlü kudretli değil mi? Fred gözünü
torpak doyursun. Fredin şu kadar da
toprağa konarsa e Fred'in ekip
biçebileceği tek başına burası. Peki
burayı Fred adına kim ekip biçecek? İşte
orada devreye kim girdi? Hop şu adam
girdi. Bunun da burnu sivri. Çeneler
beşken. Şöyle yanaklarını yaptık. Şöyle
yaptık. Bunun gözlerde sivri. Al. Fred
oldu sana efendi. Barni oldu sana köle.
Hayırlı uğurlu olsun. Ne ortaya çıktı?
Kölecilik ortaya çıktı. Neyden dolayı
çıktı kölecilik? Neyden dolayı çıktı?
Yerleşik yaşam ve tarımdan dolayı ortaya
çıktı. Peki öpücük ödüllü soru sana.
Öpücük ödüllü soru. Peki biz Türklerde
niye kölecilik yok? Bir yapımıza,
fıtratımıza ders. Biz kimsenin esiri,
esaretine girmeyiz, değil mi? Bir de biz
göçebeyiz abim. Göçebeyiz. İstanbul
Türkler. Biz göçebeyiz. Bizde şey yok
ki. Eleşik yaşam tarım yok ki. O yüzden
bizde kölecilik yok. Peki asıl soru şu.
Osmanlı süper yerleşik, süper tarım
yapıyor. Osmanlı'da da yok kölecilik.
Cevap İslamiyet değil. Osmanlı'da da
abim ne yok? Osmanlı'da da özel mülkiyet
yok. Topraklar komple kimin? Devletin
miri? Senin toprağın olmayınca
otomatikman neyin de olmuyor? Kölen de
olmuyor. Anladın mı? Ezberleme. Neyi
anla? Mantık anla. Hı. Hadi. Hayırlı
uğurlu olsun. Kölecilik de çıktı mı?
Çıktı. Gel bu kameraya. Buradan daha net
görürsünüz. Tamam.
Baş kameraya gel.
Bak oldu. Tam tutturdum vallahi. Ah.
Aha. Kölecilik çıktı. Kısmi iş bölümü de
vardır diyebilir miyim? Evet
diyebilirim. Nasıl? İşte erkekler
topluyor kadınlar. E işte işte erkekler
avlıyor, kadınlar topluyor ne bileyim ya
da köleler çalışıyor falan. Al bak yavaş
yavaş sınıflar bir şeyler böyle ortaya
çıkmayan sınıfı toplum yapısı böyle ona
doğru gidiyoruz ve her zaman dünyanın en
başından beri güçlüler ayakta kalıyor.
Abim sen ben zayıflarda öyle ağzını
ayırdığımızdan kalıyoruz işte bile ve
MEB kitabına giren yeni bir kavram artı
ürün. Bu kalemin ucu niye ne oldu la
buna? Niye yazmıyor bunu? Erdem bir
bakın la şuna. Tamam. Aha artı ürün yani
ihtiyaç fazlası ürün oldu ki ektik Fredl
Barney bir ektiler 5 aldılar tamam ha
dördünü Fred aldı birini dahi Barne'ye
verdi. Sonraki sene bir ektiler. Ulan
bir ektiler 50 aldılar. E bunlara 5
yetiyordu. E kalan ne olacak? Artı ürün
ne olacak? İhtiyaç fazlası ürün neyi
doğurdu? İhtiyaç fazlası ürün ticareti
doğurdu. Hayırlı uğurlu olsun. Yeni bir
kavram ortaya çıktı. Ticaret yani
ihtiyaç yazmıyor bu karım. Ha bunu bir
değiştireyin bana.
Aha kafası yarıldı. A ihtiyaç fazlası
üretim neyi doğurdu?
İhtiyaç fazlası üretim ticareti doğurdu.
Ticaretle beraber.
Vallahi adamsın lan. İyi yakaladım ha.
Aha. Ticaretle beraber insanoğlu
arasında kültürel etkileşim de artar mı?
Evet. Artar diyeceğiz. Peki beraberinde
bak etkileşim de artıyor. Ticaret
yapıyoruz ama para var mı? Yok. Ticaret
ne usulü yapılıyor? Takas usulü
yapılıyor. Al gülüm ver gülüm. İki inek
veriyorsun. Bir tavuk alıyorsun. Bir iki
buğday. İki ine bir tavuk olur mu lan?
Tamam. İki tavuk veriyorsun. İşte buğday
alıyorsun. Arpa alıyorsun. Toğbluk
alıyorsun. Onları yer değiştiriyorsun.
Anlaştık. Bilin. Beraberinde insanoğlu
bu dönem bitki lifinden elbise yapmaya
da başladı. Ha önceki senenin modası
neydi? İncir yaprağıydı. Öyle
koşturuyordun. Şimdi ketenden, kotondan,
bitki lifinden, hayvan derisinden böyle
neler başladı? Evsel başladı. Şimdi
buraya şöyle soruyor. ÖSYM diyor ki
artık insanoğlu doğaya hükmetmeye
başladı mı? Gördün bak doğanın üstüne
çıkmaya başlamış. Artık kontrol bize
geçmeye başlamış. Elbiseler falan
başlamış. Hah kızlar ben bugün ne
giyeceğim derdi. Ne zaman başlamış?
Burada başlamış. beraberinde beraberinde
toprağın pişirilmesiyle
yeni bir sanat ortaya çıktı. Ne sanatı?
Seramik sanatı ortaya çıktı. Hayırlı
uğurlu olsun. Çanak çömlek.
Al. Beraberinde neler çıktı? Beraberinde
saklama
kapları
ortaya çıktı. Ya bak saklama kabı. Al.
Peki ateş olmaydı,
ateş bulunmayaydı seramik sanatı olur
muydu, olmaz mıydı? Davut olmazdı.
Anlaştık. Genel kültür olsun. Toprağı
pişirdiler. Yoğura yoğura ede derken
çanak çömlek yapılmaya başlandı. Al.
İhtiyaçlarımız birbirine benziyor.
Beraberinde özel mülkiyet diye bir
kavram ortaya çıktı. Yani benim
benim benim benim damgalar, mühürler
anladın? O siciliografyalar değil mi?
Herikler bunlar yavaş yavaş ortaya
çıkmaya başladı ve beraber bak özel
mülkiyet. Hatta sana burada düşeceğim
bir şey daha. Süs eşyası,
çakı çakmak, aynarak, incik boncuk,
kolye, küpe, süs eşyası, özel mülkiyeti
gösterir mi, göstermez mi? Gösterir.
Niye? Yüzük benim yüzüğüm. Yüzük benim
yüzüğüm. Saat benim saatim, bileklik
benim bilekliğim. İşte kolye benim
kolyem. Değil mi? Bak devletin kolyesi
olmaz. Devletin inci boncu olmaz.
Anladın? kişilerin olur. Süs eşyası neyi
gösterir? Özel mülkiyeti gösterir.
Güçlüysen sahibi olursun. Beraberinde
ilkel, oklar, yaylar, hoppa silahlar
neye başladı? Çeşitlenmeye başladı.
Önceki dönemde ne vardı? Taş, balta
vardı. Şimdi ne çıktı? Oklar, yaylar
çıktı. Beraberinde İskitlerle beraber
tekerleğin de icat edildiğini biliyoruz.
Ve uzun mesafeli göçler ve insanoğlu
merak duygusuyla bir sağa sola oraya
buraya bir gidelim falan der. Bak
bununla alakalı filmler var. Mesela,
eee,
milattan önce 10.000 diye bir film var.
BC 10.000, Before Christ. İsa'dan önce
10.000 diye. Mesela bak izleyin bak. Şey
yapar. Buz devri. Allah'ım benim en
sevdiğim animasyonlardan birisi odur
yani. İzleyin. Vallahi bu dönem şey
gözünüzde canlanır yani. Hani tamam
bilin işte Konya Çatalöyük değil mi?
Beraberinde Burdur Hacılar. O zaten işte
Konya Çatalöyük eee beraberinde
Diyarbakır Çayönü. İşte dünya üzerindeki
ilk yerleşim yeri ilk üretim merkezi
diye geçiyordu. Şimdiki map kitabında
ben görmedim. Bahsetmemiş bile. Ama şunu
anlamanızı istiyorum bir de sizden. Bak
burası 600.000 yıldı. Burası 12.000
yıldı. Burası 10.000 yıl. Maden devri
5.000 yıla düşmüş. Yani insanlığın bilgi
birikimi arttıkça dönemler de ne olmuş?
Kısalmış. Yani level atlar gibi düşünün
burayı. Tamam. Burası 600.000 yıl,
12.000 yıl, 10.000 1000 yıl, 5000 yıl
falan derken anlaştık mı? Yattı mı
aklına? İnsanların bilgi birikimi
arttıkça yaz şuraya Cavar yaz. Yaz
insanların bilgi birikimi arttıkça hoppa
ne oluyor? Bilgi birikimi arttıkça
dönemler kısalmaya
başlıyor. Tamam. Yani daha hızlı ne
atlıyoruz? Level atlıyoruz. Şurası
aklınıza yattı mı? Taşla uğraştık.
Tamam. Aha taş, orta taş, yeni taş değil
mi? Karanlık çağ, yontma taş, cilalı taş
diyebilir. Tamam. Ama kırıldığımız
sosyal devinim nerede başlıyor?
Yenitaşta.
Cilalıtaş dediğimiz yerde. Niye? Çünkü
göçebelikten yerleşik yaşama geçtik.
Tamam. Buralarda yerleşik yaşam yok,
tarım yok, üretim yok. Burada başlıyor
ama ikisi için de ortak taş aletlerin
kullanılması ortaktır diyebilir miyiz?
Diyebiliriz. Bir de size burada klasik
bir TYT AYT yorumu. Aşağıdakilerden
hangisi kesin tarım yapıldığına kanıttır
diye sorarlar. Tamam. Bak orak sabanla
orak bildin mi böyle tarlayı şey
yapıyorsun ya saban böyle 3 kü boya
pulluk tarlayı sürüp gidiyorsun ya. Bak
orak sabanla sulama kanalı bunlar kesin
tarım yapıldığına kanıttır. Tamam
tohumluk kesin tarım yapıldığına
kanıttır. Ama saklama kabı
kesin tarım yapıldığını gösterir mi?
Göstermez. Başka yerden almışsın,
gelmişsindir, saklıyorsundur. Değirmen
taşı göstermez. Başka yerden almışsın,
gelmişsindir, kullanıyorsundur. Tahıl
ambarları göstermez. Anladın? Niye?
Başka yerden kalmışsın, gelmişsin
istiflemişsindir. Anlaştık. Klasik,
klişe bunlar şeyin sorularıdır. Tamam.
ÖSYM sorularıdır. Bileyin. Ve insanoğlu
yavaş yavaş derken geldim. Hop gel en
son kameraya gel köşeye. Tamam.
İnsanoğlu önce taşla uğraştı, sonra
toprakla uğraştı. Sonra toprağın içinde
neyi keşfettik? Madenleri keşfettik. En
çok doğada safalde bulunan maden
hangisi? Bakır. Bakırı kullanmaya
başladık ama bakır hemen eğiliyor,
bükülüyor. Bir halta yaramıyor, değil
mi? Bir zaman sonra bakırı kalayla
birleştirdiler. Aa bir dakika. Ateş
olmasaydı, geniş açıya geç. Ateş
olmasaydı
maden devri olur muydu?
Olmazdı değil mi? Niye? E çünkü nasıl
eriteceksin? Bakarı, kalayı, bilmem neyi
ıvır zıvır al. Anlaştık. Gel şimdi. Ateş
o yüzden önemli. Ateş hem seramiği tamam
hem de maden devrinin oluşumunda önemli
bir etkiye sahip. Bakırı kalayla
birleştirdiler. Tunçu elde ettiler.
Sonra da neyi buldular? Demiri buldular.
Ve unutma demire hükmeden dünyaya da
hükmeder. Anlaştık. Nokta atışı bilgi.
Beraberinde bak bu dönemde 5500 yıl
sürmüş. Niye? Bilgi birikimimiz arttıkça
leveller ne oluyor? dönemler kısalıyor.
Beraberinde bu dönem sınıf ayrımı artık
belirgin. Kim köle, kim efendi, kim
güçlü, kim zayıf. Onlar böyle zayıf hep
ezildiği bir dünyada yaşıyorsun. Sen de
tam en sonuna denk geldin. Kurban
olduğum kal. Tamam. Silahlarda
çeşitlenme var. Niye artık demir kılıç?
Artık tahtadan ok yok. Demirden kılıç,
demirden kalkan, bilmem ne var. E bunlar
savaştığı zaman kim daha etkili olur? Bu
taraf daha etkili olur. Beraberinde
devletleşme başladı. Al
insanoğlu baktı ki ortak düşmanlar
geliyor. Baktı olmayacak. Birleşmeye
başladılar. Sümerlerle beraber
Mezopotamya'da ilk devletleşme kültürü
de ortaya çıktı. Birlikten kuvvet
doğuyor ve bu dönem kültürel
etkileşimler de hızlanmaya başladı.
Nasıl? Bak kültürel etkileşimin o
dönemki yolları savaş, göç ve ticaret
değil mi? Göç ticaret doğalanı savaş
barbar olanı değil mi? Bununla alakalı
da şöyle sorularla geliyor. ÖSYM bak
arkanaslanme dinle. Diyor ki arkeolojik
bir kazı yapan ekip tamam mı? Kazmışlar
kazmışlar kazmışlar kazmışlar kazmışlar.
Sırasıyla toprağın en üstünden en altına
doğru kazmış kazmış kazmış kazmış. Demir
kılıç
bulmuştur diyor. Az daha kazmış tunçtan
tas bulmuştur diyor. Az daha kazmış
bakırdan
ne bileim işte ne bulsun. Bilenzik
bulsun. Bakır bilezik bulmuş. Az daha
kazmış. Yanmış buğday tanesi bulmuş.
Yanmış buğday. az daha kazmış taş balta
bulmuştur diyor. Bu yerleşim yeri ile
alakalı çıkarılabilecek en kapsamlı
yargı nedir diye sorar. Ne? Önce taş
balta, sonra yanmış buğday, sonra bakır,
tunç, demir. Yani tarih öncesi devirleri
bu bölge sırasıyla yaşamış mı? Yaşamış.
Anladın mı soru tipini? Ama burada
dikkat edeceğin olay şu. Tamam mı?
Aşağıdan yukarıdan der. Yani senden şunu
bilmeni ister. Soru eski taş, orta taş,
yeni taş, bakır, tunç demir sırasını
bilmeni ister. Anlaştık. Hah. Nokta dışı
soru tipi. Bir, ikincisi. Peki. Peki.
Bizim eleman kazıyor, kazıyor, kazıyor,
kazıyor. Demir kılıç buluyor. Tunçtan
tas buluyor. Bakır bilezik buluyor.
Başka da bir halt bulamıyor. Ne oldu
lan? Uçtu mu bunlar? Ne oldu? Bunlar ne
oldu? lar bak ne olmuş olabilir bu ekip
göç etmiş olabilir bu ekip bu ekip
yontma taşı cilalı taşı tamam mı bakır
devrini bir yerde yaşıyorken
kaldırmıştır mesela orada deprem
olmuştur tamam e orası yaşanılır halden
çıkmıştır sel olmuştur ne bile bir şey
olmuştur tamam orada doğa afeti olmuştur
orası yaşanılır olmaktan çıkmıştır bu
adamlar da göç eder buradan nereye
geldiler buraya geldiler. Şimdi oraya
geldiklerinde bir dakika biz en baştan
başlayacağız deyip eski taş, orta taş,
yontma taş oradan mı başlar? Yoksa
kaldığı yerden devam eder? Kaldığı
yerden devam ederse onunla alakalı ilk
bulunt nerede olur? Bakır bilezikle
olur. Anladın mı? Soru tipini böyle
mantık sorularıyla gelirler. Peki gene
bizim eleman kazmış kazmış kazmış
kazmış. Demir kılıç bulmuş. Tulçtan tas
bulmuş. Bakır bilezik bulmuş. Taş balta
bulmuş. Şununla alakalı bir şey
bulmamış. Ne olmuş olabilir? Ne olmuş
olabilir?
Savaş olabilir mi? Olabilir. Yontma taşı
yaşayan bir uygarlıkla, demir devrini
yaşayan bir uygarlık savaşsa, taş
baltayla Demir Kılıç savaşsa bunu kim
kazanır? E Demir Kılıç kazanır. Demir
Kılıç bunların uygarlığının üstüne çöktü
mü? Çöktü. Bu adamlar bir dakika, bir
dakika. Bir durum daha biz yortma taş
var, daha cilalı taş var, daha bakırda
tuş ter. Hop level atlarlar mı? Atlar.
Soru tipini anladın mı? Yattı mı aklına?
Böyle gelecek. Anlaştık. Al. Level
atlaya atlaya gelmişiz. Şu sırasıyla
muhabbetini soru tipi soru bankalarında
falan görürsünüz. Ve buradan bileceğiniz
olay genel yapı. Tamam. Aha tödün
özellikleri. TÖTÖD her yerde aynı anda
yaşanmamıştır. Yani tarih sürenler her
yerde aynı anda yaşan. Yani dünyanın her
yerinde. Uganda'da da Kenya'da da
Isparta'da da Burdur'da da Washington'da
da işte ne bile Seattle'da da tamam mı?
Pekin'de de, Bangkok'ta da, ne bileyim
Ötükente'de de, Semerkant değil
abiciğim. Günümüzde bile Amerika uzaya
uydu gönderiyor. Tamam. Hala Afrika'nın
ortasında yontma taş dev yaşayan
kabileler var. Doğru mu? Gelişmişlik
düzeyi her yerde aynı değildir. Bak
nokta dışı bilgi. Günümüzde bile öyle.
Mesela Mezopotamya yazıyı bulduğunda
Anadolu hala yontma taş devrini
yaşıyordu. Mesela gelişmişlik düzeyi
aynı değildir. Bir iki tarih öncesi de
birler taş toprak maden sırasını takip
eder. Önce taşla uğraştık sonra toprağı
deşeledik sonra madene ulaştık. Anlaştık
bilin. Ve töt dediğimiz dönem taranüst
devrler kullanılan araç gereçlere göre
ayrılır. Herif taşı kullanmış taş devri.
madeni kullanmış. Maden devri değil mi?
Ama tarihi devirler milattan önce
3200'lerde yani şuranın sonuna doğru
maden devrinin sonuna doğru m 3200'lerde
tamam bu Sümerler yazıyı bulunca tarih
öncesi devir bitti. Ne başladı? İlk çağ
başladı. Sonra orta çağ, yeni çağ, yakın
çağ. Peki onlar neye göre ayrılıyor?
Tarihi devirler ise toplumsal olaylara,
evrensel olaylara göre yazının icadı ilk
çağı başlattı. Kavimler göçü orta çağı
başlattı. İstanbul'un fetti yeni çağı
Fransız ihtilali de yakın çağı başlattı.
Anlaştık. Biri kullanılan araç gerece
göre tarih öncesi devirler. Tamam. Bir
öbürü de tarihi devirlerde toplumsal
evrensel olaylara göre olmuş. Ve bu
dönem bilmeni istediğim genel bir şey
daha var. Bu dönem Yontuk Taş'ta, Orta
Taşta, Calıtaşta, Bakır Tunç Demir'de
her şey var. Ne yok? Yazı yok. Tamam.
Çünkü yazıyla beraber ne başlayacak? İlk
çağ başlayacak. Ama sana yazı demez. Kil
tablet der. Herifler kağıda mı
yazıyordu? Kil tablete yazıyordu. Sonra
papirus, parşöen, Mısır'da, Yunan'da
kağıtlar çıktı mı? Çıktı. Bu dönem her
şey var. Ne yok?
Yazı yokmuş. Tamam. Gel orta kameraya.
Aklın hayattı mı? Al. Burayla alakalı.
Kesinli enli hepli soruyu bekleme.
Burası sürekli değişir durur. Ama genel
yapısı budur. Burayla alakalı yorum
sorularıyla gelir. Tamam. Verir sana
bilgiler. Göçebeydi şöyle yapıyordu.
Bitk elbise yapıyordu. İşte insanoğlu
doğa insana hükmediyor. İnsan doğaya
hükmediyor falan der. İşte şüs eşyası
vardı. İşte kölecilik vardı. bir şey
vardı falan. Bununla alakalı yorum
sorularıyla gelir. Kaldırıp da ezberleme
orta taşta Erbiz köpek mi falan falan
seneye kitap gene güncellenir gene
değişir bunlar. Tamam. Çünkü burası
tamamen yoruma açık ve Urfa
Göbeklitaş'ın eee o bulunması,
Göbeklitepe'nin bulunması burayı ciddi
manada değiştirdi. Orası komple buralar
hep değişecek ama hemen değişmez. Tamam
mı? Bunlar bir 5 10 yılı bulur dedim.
Burayı anladığınızı umuyorum. Fredle
Barne benden size hediye kalsın. Hanım
hanım bunlar benim yavrularım. Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere. Haydi
bakalım. Allah'a emanetsiniz.